initiating satellite scan
I've been playing battlefield games ever
since battlefield 2 it was 2005 I was 14
years old and I had a busted-ass PC that
would take forever to boot the game up
but oh boy did I love that game and now
I've played every battlefield game since
2142 battlefield 3 both bad company
games as well as the Vietnam expansion
Battlefield 4 hardline battlefield 1
bloody hell I even played a bunch of
Battlefield Heroes but in every single
game in the series you'd see the same
thing on the spawn screen the little
blue arrow representing one of your
teammates just straight up out in the
middle of nowhere
sometimes it being a soul player trying
to flank alone or steal a vehicle from
the spawn or a support using mortars
miles away from the frontline sitting on
an ammo pack but let's be real for the
most part it was a recon player sitting
on a hill somewhere a few feet away from
a respawn beacon
and even if it wasn't a lone player the
sight of small groups wandering away
from the objective on their own little
escapade was always kind of a
frustrating sight even more so if you
were unfortunate enough to share a squad
with these players those who couldn't
find the capture point if the flag was
stuck up their ass anyway back to the
point I really wanted to make and that
is during my hours with battlefield 5
I've noticed that the small pockets of
groups wandering the map are much less
common and the lone wolf is almost a
thing of the past the editions that dice
have made the classic battlefield
formula has paid off in a big way when
it comes to how the players at each team
worked together being that lone wolf is
not only much less viable but it's
actually a lot less fun now too no
matter what class you play as if you're
alone you're gonna struggle recons will
get spotted and kind of sniped by a
communicative team if they're sat in the
back assaults will burn through ammo and
health packs through a combination of
automatic fire and aggression
medics aren't able to put down the
weight of fire necessary for them to
take on multiple opponents especially
arranged supports like the mobility to
defend themselves from attacks from
their flanks and are among the juiciest
targets for enemy snipers communication
and teamwork have always been powerful
tools in the battlefield series that is
a fact that fortifies the backbone of
the franchise but now in battlefield 5
teamwork is essential and
that's why I love it you can beg you
yard the attrition system is something
dice have spoken about a lot during the
lead-up to Battlefield 5's release and
this is a big reason why it's more
important than ever to stick with your
team but it's by no means the only
reason for those of you who may be
unfamiliar with the way the attrition
system works right now the upshot is
that the solitary soldier is much weaker
in battlefield 5 than there were in
previous games they carry less
ammunition and fewer grenades they're
unable to heal to full without using a
first-aid kit and most soldiers only
carry one life-saving bandage and you
can pick up a few rounds of ammo from
fallen enemies but that's not very
viable in a sustained firefight
especially since it means leaving any
solid cover you may have all of this
lends itself toward a cohesive squad
being much more than the sum of its
parts there isn't a moment where you're
at a loss of a way to support your team
beyond taking down enemies assistance to
your squad mates breeds a kind of
positive feedback loop the ability to
revive your buddies regardless of your
class means that you can keep a strong
frontline and keep pushing the objective
supports throwing up defenses keeps the
squad safe and an appointed strength
medics thrown around bandages means that
other members can be a little more self
sustaining and even if recons can't hit
the broad side of a barn they can still
spot a flanker exact enemy positioning
with shots telescopes or flares the
necessity to work together even
influences the way vehicles are treated
now similarly to real-life military
engagements tanks need to be supported
by infantry turrets turned far too
slowly to effectively engage charging
assault troops if they get too close so
having that backup as part of a
four-person fighting group is imperative
to keeping engines running
their sense of purpose and the way
you're rewarded for sticking with the
squad breeds a kind of loyalty even a
camaraderie in some scenarios taking a
heavily defended conquest flag with your
squad at your side makes you want to
stick together for as long as you can
stay in the same server I've had moments
in a game where I've watched a medic
I've just randomly been squatted up with
rushed through gunfire popping smokes on
the move just to get me back up and into
the fight after seeing that you know
damn well I made sure they had ammo
aplenty and I'd picked their screaming
selves back up as soon as I saw them
down on the ground
buddhir time fine boy boss nice yeah
funny a funny dive no you haven't
cheers me on mucker
our field has always been grounded in
the idea of teamwork but it has never
had such an emphasis on it on supporting
the soldier your side and I think that's
the main reason why I love this latest
entry so much now I used to have a
really close-knit group of friends who
had boots up battlefield three nearly
every night but over the years we
drifted apart and we didn't gain as much
I found myself missing that sense of
working together as part of a unit
towards the same objective and while I
don't have the same group of pals
anymore I can now get similar
experiences with nearly anyone I'm
squatting up with because to me the
emphasis on teamwork has felt a little
lacking in previous battlefield titles
but now with the changes and additions
dice have made two battlefield 5 I feel
like players get to be part of something
bigger with each match whether it's a
friend or a stranger I feel like we're
working together and that's exactly what
a game of Battlefield should feel like
like a valuable cog in the 32 play a
machine that makes up your team as great
as the game looks as great as it plays
it's been a pleasant surprise to find
that it's actually the teamwork on
display that stood out as my favorite
element about the new title but I want
to know how you found it
do you feel the difference from
battlefield 1 and 4 and how do you like
to play in a squad let me know in the
comments section below or find me on
Twitter at irregular Dave I hope you've
enjoyed this video and remember ladies
and gentleman always thank your medic
by chance manga